vendredi soir enfin la fin de la semaine
qu'est ce que je vais attendu ce ver
c'était bon bon ok retour à la maison
le travail s'est fait plus que 700 m 700
mètres à pied je suis chez moi ok un peu
de musique
ça va être bon allez on regarde à droite
à gauche
c'est parti on y va quelqu'un sur le
banc qui nous regardent un hockey non
vas-y traces traces tracé bon ok c'est
passé en fait on enlève la musique qui
tu tu entendras mieux ce qui se passe
autour
on sait jamais à gauche une camionnette
fait fait un tour fait un tour large
ok ça s'est passé ok le lampadaire qui
fonctionne plus ok tu vas tracé un peu
plus vite sur cette portion
dans à peu près dit m le prochain
lampadaires à les 500 m 500 m qui est
500 m ok au quelqu'un droit devant
quelqu'un droit devant on va se croiser
analyse hockey et rentre du boulot père
de famille la cinquantaine
ça va le faire savoir ok avance avance 4
100 m 400 m on s'est croisé ça y est
c'est bon on s'est croisé à ok une bande
de gars droit devant à 200 mètres à peu
près panique qui paniquent nom sortait
clé sortez clé vas-y entre les doigts
celle là c'est le plus tranchantes
on sait jamais
ça le fait on y tourne à gauche tourner
à gauche c'est bon ok 300 mètres 300
mètres ils ont tourné à gauche
jusque là tout s'est super bien passé ok
choisi continue d'avancer des pas
derrière toi ok j'attends un petit coup
d'oeil un deuxième je sais pas j'ai rien
du hockey super ok super quelqu'un
derrière moi oh non c'est le type du
banc oh non c'est le type du banc ces
lectures
ok ok calme-toi marche dit marie vite
200 mètres 200 mètres et y ait 200 m ok
c'est le type du banc il m'appelle et
non mais mademoiselle y en a plus on est
mademoiselle non je suis la seule ok
c'est peut-être quelqu'un d'autre qui
parle au vent non ok bon ils se
rapprochent qui se rapproche
ok ça va bien se passer ça berce de ces
restes qui aimeraient se tienne je suis
charmante prendre un verre
non merci ok avance ça va le faire
ça va le faire avance il insiste insiste
toi aussi
non merci c'est très gentil non merci ok
c'est bon sens m 100 m et ye or c'est
bon il est parti ok 100 m voici la clé
dans la porte
la porte derrière toi c'est fermé ok
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais bien voir cet accueil corps
je rentre chez moi
ok donc ça c'était 700 m 700 mètres
c'est pas très longue 700 mètres ça
arrive souvent à plein d'entre nous
pourtant c'est pas forcément la même
expérience pour tout le monde et pour
cause
en fait mon impression c'est que la rue
ne m'appartient pas alors pourquoi est
ce que je dis ça c'est à dire que la rue
en fête et définit comme un espace
public et en espace public c'est quoi
c'est un espace qui techniquement est
censé être partagée par tout le monde
un espace de rencontre tout ça sauf que
pour moi en fait la rue qu'est ce que
c'est au mieux ce juste en bout de temps
que je dois passer qui est pas trop
désagréable qui est ensoleillée et ça se
passe bien par contre au pire
c'est un espace de tous les dangers
c'est à dire que là mon cerveau se met
en mode répugnant avec tous les signaux
de peur tout ça vous a expliqué et du
coup là tout est un potentiel danger
donc d'ailleurs je suis très désolé si
j'ai croisé certains d'entre vous que
j'ai identifié comme un potentiel danger
voilà je suis désolé pour ça mais du
coup voilà pourquoi je vous parle de
tout ça c'est juste parce que je
voudrais qu'on se rende compte que on
n'a pas tous la même expérience de la
rue et que pour certains ça devient très
pesant mentalement et je vais vous
montrer à quel point
donc il ya quelqu'un qui s'appelle
jackson 4 et qui des fois comme moi se
retrouve devant des gens comme vous et
discuté avec eux et leur pose une simple
question qui est la suivante
que faites-vous quotidiennement pour
éviter de vous faire agresser
sexuellement alors je vous laisse tous
réfléchir un peu voilà ensuite il dresse
ce tableau là et qui donne dont deux
parties pour changer on va interroger
d'abord ces messieurs et donc qu'est ce
qui se passe à ce moment là bas souvent
en fait pas grand chose et tant mieux
pour vous genre super cool mais
mais la question c'est qu'est ce qui se
passe cette fois quand on interroge les
femmes
la liste est légèrement plus longue avec
plein de trucs fort de tips
bref vous demanderez à vos potes moi
j'aime bien les clés on sent un peu
wolverine mais sans eau on fait avec ce
qu'on a
en voilà donc il ya plein de trucs et en
fait qu'est-ce que ça fait tout ça
baisse ça fait beaucoup de charge
mentale ça fait quand 700 m notre
cerveau une surchauffe un peu il se
passe beaucoup de trucs et on est très
très content d'arriver à destination
pour vous montrer encore plus l'ampleur
de ce phénomène
peut-être que vous avez suivi il ya
quelques temps sur twitter il ya une
personne qui a posé cette question qui a
dit qu'est ce que vous feriez si tous
les hommes avaient un couvre-feu à 9
heures alors tout d'abord qu'on
s'entende bien je ne souhaite pas que
les hommes un couvre-feu 9h d'accord
j'adore aller au bar avec vous le soir
ok c'est juste pour vous montrer en fait
juste l'ampleur du problème et les
barrières consommer psychologiquement
nous mêmes donc il ya plein de réponses
qui ont été dites et souvent c'est juste
des trucs complètement fin des
situations banales par exemple juste bah
allez courir écouter de la musique
et parce que cette question où aller au
bar est rentré à n'importe quelle heure
c'est juste la même chose que d'habitude
mais sans le stress des 700 m et du coup
la réaction était vraiment genre immense
il ya tellement de gens qui ont
participé et surtout il ya aussi
quelques quelques hommes qui ont réagit
parfois en disant c'est vrai que j'y
avais pas pensé
enfin ça peut arriver que certains on
est déjà conscience que certains nous
déjà parler avec quelqu'un mais ça peut
arriver d'autres sont juste en à merde
jeu désolé ça m'est pas arrivé du coup
forcément je me suis pas posé la
question et c'est tout à fait normal
on se pose pas quarante mille questions
sur des situations qui nous arrive pas
au quotidien
du coup voilà l'idée est là maintenant
que vous savez que pour certaines
même certains c'est pas toujours
agréable de rentrer chez soi la question
est quel problème
on est tous d'accord cette dame a fait
une remarque très intéressante alors le
problème qu'on soit clair ce ne sont pas
les hommes ce sont les criminels
oui mais si on avait juste un death note
pour simplement écrire tous les
criminels dedans ça serait trop facile
bon on en a pas désolé mais du coup il
va trouver falloir il va falloir trouver
dans ce sens là c'est mieux une autre
solution
et du coup on va tous se demander qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire pour faire changer
les choses les mentalités pour que ces
700 mètres ne soit pas un calvaire et
que j'ai pas besoin de deux verres
d'aspirine ans rentre chez moi
donc qu'est ce qu'on peut faire il ya
plein de petites ou grandes solutions
déjà bien sûr il ya des choses qui
dépendent pas directement de vous comme
par exemple l'éclairage public qui est
hyper important parce que on sent quand
même un peu plus rassuré dans une rue
mieux éclairé pourquoi je vous dis tout
ça vous allez me dire oui mais c'est pas
moi qui plante des lampadaires
oui je sais mais si un jour vous avez à
voter pour quelqu'un si vous doublez en
une politicienne qui sait ayez
conscience de ce problème
ça fera plaisir à certaines voix certes
en bref la deuxième chose qu'on peut
faire
ce sont donc plus de sécurité sert que
c'est toujours bien de sa voix rauque et
je sais que c'est un problème il ya un
agent de sécurité il ya un policier il
ya quelque chose je suis pas seule
langue est pourquoi je dis ça parce que
il ya certains parfois certains campus
qui sont pas forcément assez sécurisé je
passe du 0 entendu parler de bordeaux
récemment fin bref voilà vous irez
chercher en rentrant chez vous mais du
coup voilà ça ça reste quand même assez
important et pour définir toutes ces
choses qui manquent
il ya ce qu'on appelle des marches
exploratoires
si à l'occasion vous pouvez participer à
une ses enrichissant sert quand on se
balade comme ça et puis on voit des
coins on dit
alala ce petit chemin et éclairé mais là
il ya un gros buissons il ya quatre
arbres c'est très sombre
si je suis tout seul sur ce chemin je le
sens moyens donc voilà c'est des
activités qui sont faites pour définir
les problèmes et c'est trouver des
solutions ensuite pour passer à une
échelle plus proche de nous qu'est ce
que vous pouvez faire genre maintenant
là ce soir en sortant de ce thème après
avoir bu trois bières et en entrant chez
vous par exemple qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire bain par exemple tout
simplement
c'est bête mais vous pouvez proposer à
quelqu'un si vous n'avez peut-être pas
trop loin de la raccompagner parce que
souvent en fait on va pas dire genre oh
là là je vais vous en contera compagnie
pourquoi pas ce que ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'on accepte bac on a peur et
accepté de dire j'ai peur de rentrer
chez moi ça veut dire accepter de soi
même se dire en fait je suis pas si
forte que je voudrais lettres et ça ça
je peux vous dire ça prend des fois plus
de courage que traverser 700 m du coup
voilà si vous avez l'occasion fait le
spontanément peut-être que la personne
veut dire annoncé c'est cool c'est
gentil mais pas besoin tant mieux mais
peut-être que des fois ça peut rassurer
et ensuite la plus importante des choses
pour moi c'est vraiment si un jour il
vous arrive de voir quelque chose qui
n'est pas normal juste intervenez je
vous dis pas genre sur le coup d'être à
vis de réagir d'aller [ __ ] un gros
coup de poing non juste même si vous
êtes aussi sidéré que la victime parce
que souvent la personne base il ne sait
pas comment réagir parce qu'elle s'y
attendait pas du tout juste après même
si vous prenez je sais pas 30 secondes
une minute à vous réveiller du truc
allez voir la personne qui lui est ce
que ça va est ce que tu vas bien
est-ce que tu as besoin de quelque chose
est ce que tu veux qu'on aille voir je
sais pas les agents de sécurité la
police ensemble ce que je peux faire
quelque chose pour toi juste de lui
faire comprendre que ce qu'elle vient de
vivre là c'est pas normal ça devrait pas
exister et vous ne cautionnez pas ça
mais ça fait ça va être vraiment une
révélation parce que 6 à 7 personnes qui
vient de vivre quelque chose qui n'est
pas normal qu'ils en plus
dit ok autour de moi y'a personne qui a
réagi peut-être dire que c'est de ma
faute ça veut peut-être dire qu'il faut
juste que je m'y habituer et ça ça on
peut on peut pas enfin on peut pas que
c'était ça on ne peut pas accepter que
ça continue comme ça parce que je pense
qu'on a tous envie que ça change et ça
commence comme ça juste part des petites
actions
donc pour pas regretter de rien à voir
dit prenez votre courage à deux mains et
juste guy tu en dis ça va ou est-ce que
je peux t'aider juste à et ça sera déjà
incroyable et puis ensuite un dernier
petit truc que vous pouvez faire avec
vos amis si besoin c'est par exemple sur
messenger maintenant il ya une un truc
pour se localiser où il ya d'autres apps
on peut montrer sa localisation est par
exemple nous dites à vos potes web assis
dans un quart d'heure je suis pas chez
moi
vous pourriez de checker où je suis sur
mon ap et au cas où appelez moi parce
que des fois un coup de fil ça peut
sortir d'une situation un peu compliquée
où ça peut donner une excuse ça peut
aider
voilà et ça c'est clairement pas
compliqué à mettre en place si sarah sur
des gens bah tant mieux donc du coup je
vous raconte tout ça parce que en fait
j'aimerais juste que dans pas longtemps
prochaine fois que je me balade dans la
rue au lieu de me dire toutes ces
personnes que je vois au lieu de me
faire des alertes à moi même que toutes
ces personnes que je croise soit plutôt
les personnes ration t que je me dise
yes la probabilité qui est une de ces
personnes qui soient un peu bizarre et
un peu désagréable est très faible
donc c'est à dire que toutes les autres
personnes que je croise c'est des gens
bien qu'ils seront prêts à être là et
prêts à intervenir pour moi et s'il ya
quoi que ce soit et là je peux vous dire
que les 700 m mais je vais les faire
mais tous les jours avec grand bonheur
si m6 il faut enfin voila merci beaucoup
de m'avoir écouté je voudrais juste
conclure sur cette phrase d'un rappeur
qui s'appelle vince et qui donc a dit si
leur courage m'empêche de dire le mot
victimes sachent qu'on est tous un peu
coupable merci
[Applaudissements]